à nos invités nous brûlerons ensuite un
peu kérosène pour enjamber les océans
direction la nouvelle calédonie où les
habitants se sont prononcés en faveur du
maintien au sein de la république
française lors d'un référendum ce
week-end mais le score de 56% est il
assez élevé pour qu'on puisse parler de
vraie victoire
réponse tout à l'heure nous parlerons
aussi de cet ambitieux projet de refonte
de la loi de 1905 sur la séparation des
églises et de l'état afin de tenir
compte d'un problème apparu bien après
sa mise en application
au siècle dernier je veux parler
évidemment de l'intégrisme islamiste
et puis nous terminerons sur une note
plus joyeuse moins graves avec cette
perspective de voir entrer à l'académie
française un comédien en l'occurrence
fabrice luchini qui a lancé dans le
dernier figaro magazine qu'il allait
tenter de se faire élire
bonne idée ou mauvaise idée tous ces
sujets vous pouvez vous même les
commenter sur hashtag figure la haye
mais à chaque point de vue mais vous
pouvez surtout écoutés nous inviter en
parler ses invités qui sont-ils d'abord
ilana cicurel
vous êtes membre du bureau exécutif de
la république en marche en charge
notamment de la réflexion sur les
questions liées à la culture à
l'enseignement supérieur la recherche et
l'éducation qui est un sujet qui vous
tient à coeur avec nous aussi
l'essayiste caroline valentin qui oeuvre
notamment pour le magazine causeur et
pour le figaro vox vous êtes aussi une
des contributrices du livre enquête
dirigée par georges bensoussan une
france soumise
les voies du refus publiés chez
albin-michel l'année dernière bienvenue
aussi à jean baptiste marteau
journaliste politique sur france 2 mario
il vous arrive aussi de présenter le
journal de 20h sur france 2 toujours de
participer à l'émission politique mais
entendu et vous avez publié cette année
avec mais il a la trouille le tsunami
sheila les éditions plon qui revient sur
cette campagne folle que je suis celle
de la présidentielle de 2017
enfin patrick peloux qui est devenu un
des piliers de l'émission désirons nous
est toujours président de l'association
des médecins urgentistes hospitaliers de
france et auteur de se tester dans livre
l'instinct de vie publié au cherche midi
et puis vous devez être particulièrement
heureux ce soir puisque on a appris
aujourd'hui que le prix femina revenait
à votre ancien voisin du robec de
charlie hebdo philippe lançon pour le
lambeau et très bons amis si je suis
très très heureux pour lui c'est mérité
ça c'est un livre témoignage important
et je suis très content pour lui c'est
bien mérité parce qu'il a vraiment un
grand talent du journaliste c'est bien
et du crillon et d'écrivain merci
commençons donc avec un sujet qui semble
devenu
épineux pour emmanuel macron
l'augmentation des taxes sur les prix
des carburants et notamment du diesel on
vous savez une pétition a été lancée
un blocage des routes est prévue le 17
novembre l'opposition hurle et pourtant
emmanuel macron persiste et signe comme
on a pu le lire ce matin dans le
quotidien le progrès puisqu'il nous dit
on nous a expliqué pendant dessine
pendant des décennies qu'il fallait
acheter du diesel et maintenant c'est le
contraire c'est normal que ce soit mal
compris
j'assume parfaitement que la fiscalité
du ou diesel soit au niveau de celles de
l'essence et je préfère la taxation du
carburant à la taxation du travail une
justification qui ne passe pas son nom
juge par le succès d'une vidéo postée il
ya quelques semaines par une
automobiliste jacqueline moureaux que je
vous propose de découvrir ainsi qu'une
partie de la réponse de la secrétaire
d'état à la transition écologique et
solidaire
emmanuelle wargon par twitter maintenant
tous nos véhicules diesel vous dérange
alors il faut les changer même c'est pas
pour ça m'oblige et du pognon pour
changer ma voiture à vos petites primes
est de rien du tout un ça va pas suffire
à changer tout un parc automobile
français quand on change de voiture on
passe aussi une voiture qui consomme
plus à une voiture qui consomme moins
si on passe de 800 à 4 litres aux 100 en
faisant 25000 km par an comme le disait
jacqueline on économise mille litres
d'essence par an aux mille litres de
diesel c'est à dire environ 1500 euros
qui s'ajoutent aux deux mille euros de
prime à la conversion qui devrait
normalement être complétée par les
constructeurs automobiles
donc ça commence à devenir possible de
changer de véhicule
encore une balle en temps vous êtes
convaincus par le gouvernement par sa
défense d'un côté c'est vrai que la
pollution est principalement due aux
transports terrestres ça on peut pas
dire le contraire
le seul problème c'est que y'a plein de
territoires dans lesquels la voiture
reste nécessaire est obligatoire et
ensuite il n'y a pas non plus deux
de d'alternative à la voiture à essence
en tout cas pas d'alternative crédible
puisque aujourd'hui une voiture
électrique mais quand même un temps de
recharge très long je crois que la
production de voitures va atteindre les
100 millions pour cette année ou l'année
prochaine pour les voitures électriques
on est à un million
et c'est quand même aussi effectivement
c'est ce que dit la dame qui s'exprime
c'est très cher de changer de voiture et
les français n'ont plus d'argent donc
l'idée est bonne fondamentalement mais
c'est trop tôt c'est trop tôt sans
alternative et c'est toujours été le cas
c'est comme en allemagne voyez
l'allemagne a abandonné le nucléaire est
ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont fait du
charbon en charbon pollue encore plus
qu'elle petra l'a donc sur ce point
précis le gouvernement a tort de santé
devrait revenir gouvernement doit
commencer par faire une une politique
positive qui consiste à d'abord
favoriser l'émergence d'alternatives
crédibles et ensuite aider les français
à changer de voiture plutôt que sans
arrêt les plomber les taxer et affecter
leur pouvoir d'achat
patrick pelloux la raison 100 des 200
pas de s'embêter fonction était aussi
d'ailleurs mais de s'entêter le
gouvernement il a complètement raison
il a complètement interdit cap et il a
raison de maintenir le cap d'une part
parce que il ya des choses qu'on ne
connaît pas encore suffisamment et qui
sont dans la recherche scientifique si
les conséquences de la pollution et des
microparticules je vous rappelle que si
vous vivez à paris par rapport à
quelqu'un qui vit dans le grand air ou
dans les montagnes a une espérance de
vie qui irait de moins de 5 ans quand
même c'est considérable donc il faut le
faire c'est pas agréable
maintenant c'est aux pouvoirs politiques
parce que finalement ce débat là est
beaucoup plus politique que ce qu'on
croit en fait ce que vous pouvez pas
avoir une population qui est de plus en
plus inquiète fort justement sur le
réchauffement climatique qu'on voit
maintenant au quotidien avec les des
canicules les excès de la nature avec
les tempêtes etc
et puis de l'autre camp à coup il s'agit
de balayer devant votre porte vous
non non il n'est pas question je ne
changerai pas des habitudes oui c'est
pénible
il faut trier ses poubelles il faut
changer radicalement faut prendre le
vélo il faut avoir quand rien ne va
comment tu fais dans les campagnes c'est
là où c'est éminemment politique parce
que c'est la bataille non l'annoncé hier
après sa menace afin que les espérances
d'amiens mais c'est c'est là où il ya
une véritable question politique
d'aménagement du territoire qui compte
d'un coup tu as la ligne 2 de la ligne
de train que je connais bien entre
grenoble et gap qui passe par luce
lacroix haute d'accord cette ligne elle
a été quasiment abandonnée
il faut redécouvrir le train les
transports en commun c'est là où il ya
besoin c'est là où plutôt que de dire et
de tenter d'expliquer que le pouvoir
d'achat va augmenter ce qui n'est pas
forcément vrai ou qu'il n'a pas bougé et
c'est ce qui est pas forcément vrai on
est tout à fait d'accord il faudrait
mieux dire non mais regardez en même
temps on vous construit des transports
en commun on va vous dire ça et non ils
ne disent pas c'est que j'ai une bonne
nouvelle pour vous parler en fait un peu
comme comme bruno le maire je mise de
l'économie est comme gilles legendre qui
est le président du groupe la république
on marche à l'assemblée nationale c'est
le premier thé sur rmc le deuxième
souffle chanteur koteas esprits est-ce
que la hausse des taxes sur les
carburants
prévu le 1er janvier sera suspendu non
ne sera pas suspendu
nous ne devons pas renoncer à notre
objectif qui les vend des transports
moins polluants
on doit changer et on doit changer
maintenant tout le monde dit les la
prime à la conversion qui permet de
transformer de remplacer son véhicule
c'est une prime pour les riches c'est
faux elle explose en ce moment la prima
conversion elle a tellement de succès qu
on est déjà à la moitié de ce qu'on
avait prévu pour l'ensemble du
quinquennat et qui en profite à 75 % des
ménages non imposables
je vous vois opiné du chef de l'institut
elle est sur la même longueur d'onde
bien entendu oui oui bien entendu mais
joe pinet du chef parce qu'effectivement
cette grand ce grand succès de la prime
à la conversion qui profitent même à 90
% si on enlève l'ile-de-france home et
aux ménages les plus modestes et bien
c'est un signe il faut aller dans ce
sens-là je suis contente de parler juste
après un médecin urgentiste pas ce
qu'est ce que vous connaissez le nombre
de victimes par an qu'on considère comme
de mort contre résultant de la pollution
de l'air se dépenser les particules
fines particules fines
on est à 48 47 milles voilà on est on
est on est sur des chiffres quand même
et c'est un problème de santé publique
majeur
moi ce que je trouve assez assez
étonnant dans cette histoire c'est que
l'ensemble des candidats à la
présidentielle était favorable à ce
qu'il y ait un alignement du diesel sur
l'essence parce qu'on en est là le
premier niveau de mesure c'est de se
dire il faut que le diesel qui est
tellement polian ne soit pas dans un
état de faveur donc on est déjà sur
l'alignement et ensuite on parle d'une
augmentation progressive ce qui a un
petit peu compliqué les choses c'est le
prix du pétrole mais c'est une raison de
plus pour effectivement devenir autonome
par rapport au pétrole et à aller dans
le sens de cette transition écologique
donc moi je suis reconnaissante à
emmanuel macron d'être comme aimait
comme pierre mendès france lui demander
de gouverner et donc de choisir
gouverner c'est choisir
c'est donc faire des arbitrages et j'ai
l'impression de tout le temps assister à
une cour une politique qui est courageux
dans les différents domaines on y
reviendra peut-être ou forcément vous
n'avez jamais de mesures absolument
parfaite où il n'y a aucun effet pervers
et évidemment que nous sommes en pleine
compassion avec tous les gens qui
aujourd'hui souffrent au quotidien de
cette mesure c'est pour cela que nous
avons imaginé que nous allons continuer
à mettre en place des dispositifs qui
vont leur permettre et on voit que ça
fonctionne puisque c'est eux qui en
profitent d'acquérir en fait des des
voitures non polluantes
et j'ajoute que il y a les voitures
hybrides ou électriques mais il ya aussi
les voitures récentes moins polluantes
donc on est dans un spectre assez large
qui va quand même permettre une
acquisition ça va jusqu'à 2500 euros et
la secrétaire d'état emmanuelle wargon
le rappeler c'est aussi une économie
parce que quand vous vous ne vous n'êtes
plus dépendants à l'essence et bien au
bout d'un moment ça va jusqu'à 1000
euros d'économie par par an pour pour
quelqu'un qui en moyenne
donc voilà en tout cas oui nous sommes
sales écoute mais en même temps gardons
le cap et 7 70% de cette augmentation
elle est due à la hausse du carburant ce
qui doit nous
inciter à autonomiser et être dans une
politique de responsabilité parce que
c'est un problème de santé publique et
je suis je m'occupe d'éducation et bien
je peux vous dire que dans parmi les 48
milles je pense que patrick peloux
confirmerait il ya beaucoup de jeunes
donc je pense que là on doit être en
responsabilité c'est difficile c'est
difficile pour tout le monde
il faut imaginer des dispositifs étant
ces dispositifs mais il faut sûrement
pas reculer je crois tout le monde
comprend cette argumentation il
n'empêche que à l'image de on a posé la
question sur twitter selon vous le
gouvernement a t-il raison de s'entêter
au sujet de l'augmentation du carburant
oui 19% non 80% il ya quand même une
grogne inédite depuis l'arrivée
d'emmanuel d'un cran il me semble sur ce
sujet qui prend une ampleur
est ce que c'est une ampleur inédite est
ce que ça vous rappelle une situation
précédente politiquement ne sais pas
l'entêtement droit dans ses bottes
jean-baptiste marteau et une énième la
croûte des conseils il est face à
plusieurs problèmes c'est effectivement
il ya le prix de l'essence qui monte
s'ajoutent à lui fait un prix s'ajoute à
ces hausses de taxes déjà ça tombe mal
d'un point de vue calendrier en plus
c'est comme un mois sur lequel on devait
parler pouvoir d'achat puisque tout le
monde à gagner du pouvoir d'achat sur sa
fiche de paie de couteau au mois de mai
avec la cotisation chômage qui ont été
supprimés donc là ça sert à rien pou
font là-bas ce qu on l'a balayé une
mesure qui coûte effectivement assez
cher donc la série 200 euros donc il ya
un certain nombre de dispositions sont
là pour compenser malgré tout c'est vrai
que on entend partout
cette espèce de petite musique qui
montent comme ça alors que quand vous
regardez les arguments un peu calmement
froidement c'est quand même le concours
lépine des arguments parfois les plus
fous j'ai dit excusez moi je n'ai jamais
entendu on regarde la vidéo de cette
dame qui buzze manière assez
hallucinantes sur internet
gentil mais elle dit quand même un
nombre de voix la bêtise ou à vue sinon
quand elle dit ils ont de l'argent pour
racheter la vaisselle de l'elysée et
faire construire des piscines mais voilà
bon c'est très gentil mais le groupe
malgré tout s'apprend et c'est vrai que
là je pense qu'un gros problème de
communication une nouvelle offre
c'est à dire qu'on se retrouve avec le
même problème que lors de la sphère
benalla lors de toutes les affaires qui
ont lu depuis la rentrée le gouvernement
laisse passer laisse min et la
mayonnaise un peu dans l'opinion et
tardent à réagir
je pense qu emmanuel macron là quand on
commence enfin à essayer d'expliquer
pourquoi il ya cette mesure qui peut se
comprendre mais certains restent trop
faibles
il faut l'expliquer les besoins de
pédagogie énormément sur cette question
patrick peu loin
on est dans une époque où la bêtise
devient ses lettres de noblesse ou d'un
coup des gens qui expriment de manière
maladroite leur souffrance avec des
arguments qui n'en sont pas ça fait le
buzz et ça ça qu'aux adultes illustre sa
coagule un malaise profond
voilà il ya un malaise profond et un
malaise profond parce qu'il ya un peuple
qui à mon avis est dans une très grande
souffrance
ça fait à peu près 30 ou 40 ans qu'on
lui dit la même chose sur la crise sur
les difficultés est a l'impression que
chaque jour il ya une difficulté
supplémentaire
donc c'est sûr que l'argument de la dame
donc on peut qu'on peut contester mais
qui est réel ils ont la pression ma foi
que que l'élysée rachète de l'année
celle bas il faut racheter de la
vaisselle bon après il ya tout ce
qu'elle évoque
pour eux c'est des signes qui sont qui
sont pas juste par rapport à la
souffrance qu'ils ont ce qui a une
réelle souffrance il ya une souffrance
notamment des personnes âgées il ya une
souffrance des plus jeunes les plus
jeunes il arrive de plus en plus
tardivement sur le marché du travail ils
sont même pas sûrs d'avoir du travail et
maintenant on leur fait passer la
musique qu'il va falloir qu'il change de
formation alors pourquoi on m'a formé à
être horticulteurs et puis d'un coup on
lui dit tu vas être cafetiers et il
n'accepte pas c'est d'une violence
extraordinaire
il y à il ya une protestation très
violente et en effet d'un coup tu qu'on
leur dise avec des arguments
scientifiques prouvent est juste de dire
il faut arrêter le diesel ça vous tue
doucement
eh bien on tape là où ça fait mal le
porte monnaie
et c'est pas la première crise parce que
si vous vous souvenez bien il ya
quelques années il y avait déjà eu au
mouvement en 2012 y avait eu une
augmentation de 8 le baril a dépassé les
100 dollars est bien sûr les 100 dollars
la on effaçait voilà on touche à quelque
chose de sortie parce que la voiture
c'est la liberté
j'entends ce que vous dites mais il ya
des arguments au regard des parents chez
les internautes
quelqu'un daniel dit pourquoi ne
diminuent de thymine sûrs et ont pas les
taxes dans les zones rurales où les
travailleurs sont obligés d'utiliser
leur véhicule c'est intéressant comme et
rosa bien au nom de l'égalité
vous pouvez pas faire des taxes en
fonction d'eux
l'égalité qui vous aurait il ya un
examen qui est fait peut-être que ça
peut être intéressant d'avoir une
réflexion régionale frais de sécurité
jantes et les élites absolue c'est
injuste la partie qui a été lancé par
président de la république ce matin
justement dans l'entretien que vous
citiez donc il ya des réflexions en
cours
effectivement pour compenser et pour
effectivement avoir des aides ciblées
meilleur sur le mazout problème
effectivement plus générale moi je suis
perplexe parce que je pense que la
spécificité de ce qui est proposé par
par emmanuel macron et par le
gouvernement c'est que c'est très
systémique et vous parler de mes
problèmes de formation il est adressé
c'est à dire qu'à 15 milliards qui est
consacré à la formation qui est ciblé
justement sur ce qui n'avait pas du tout
de formation et jeu on a déjà des
résultats avec une rose de 40 % des
contrats d'apprentissage et contrats
d'alternance un donc
donc tout ça il ya s'ils voulaient à
chaque fois une réponse une cohérence un
cap et pourtant ça ne passe pas je ne
peux mais pourtant ça ne passe pas
de deux choses l'une soit c'est la
difficulté de la réforme c'est alexis de
tocqueville qui disait que un
gouvernement n'est jamais autant en
danger que quand il réforme
nous en sommes personne n'a jamais pensé
que ce serait facile de faire ces
réformes pour que tout le monde a
rechigné à faire depuis des années donc
ne soyons pas naïf on sait très bien
saliha difficile ça l'est et il ya
peut-être aussi une réflexion à avoir
sur 7 sur information qui fait qu on est
dans la myopie c'est à dire que ont fait
un zoom sur une mesure et on oublie sans
arrêt le contexte et comme on est un
pays où tout le monde réclame la réforme
mais pour l'autre mais jamais pour soi
même mais par rapport à ce problème du
carburant il faut vous plat il faut vous
placez dans 50 ou 100 ans dans 50 ou 100
ans
il faudra tordre le cou à l'énergie
fossile
voilà ce qui veut dire que là s'il y
avait la priorité des priorités serait
de chercher la révolution ayant pas
traîné
l'hydrogène je peux pas dire aux gens
ben oui comme c'est très grave pour la
santé il va falloir que vous dites
achetez une voiture là où va son chemin
c'est la guerre les genres les gens ils
arrêtent d'acheter un produit quand ça
augmente de 5 centimes
ils sont ils ont vraiment plus beaucoup
d'argent voilà voilà donc ils payent
dans une charge ils sont ils font
attention à leur budget et tout à coup
on leur dit c'est pas grave
achetez donc une voiture qui coûte quand
même plusieurs milliers d'euros ça ça
dépend soit d'essence et c'est meilleur
pour ses membres ça mais oui tu as dit
juste c'est pour ça que c'est une
véritable question politique nommé comme
comme ça a été rappelé du tout la
campagne électorale de 2017 ils ont tous
donné cet argument en disant on va
lutter contre la pollution c'est très
important au niveau de la mort hier des
moyens de tri ça va beaucoup plus loin
sa version le pouvoir d'achat est en
premier lieu de donner du travail à ses
fonctions et à celle des gens me dire
c'est que le travail paye mieux les mots
sur ce dernier mot choisi un projet de
transition elle va prendre des années il
faut l'enclencher effectivement c'est le
sens de l'histoire
maintenant concrètement emmanuel macron
il entame aujourd'hui une tournée à
travers nouvelles de la france dans
l'itinérance et ça il va être en contact
des français des zones rurales
pendant toute une semaine et là il faut
qu'il ait un geste il faut qu'il puisse
leur dire à ces gens là oui vous vous
avez besoin de votre bagnole tous les
jours et on va faire une heure 8 juin
une aide ponctuelle je n'étais pas sous
quel sort il doit faire ses annonces à
deux semaines leur façon l'utilisation
de la voix est racontée n'est pas qu'un
problème de zones rurales ces cités dans
les zones urbaines ta 95 90 des gens
maintenant qu'ils vivent à la ville il
ya des moments là on peut sembler c'est
essayer de prendre un train pour aller
de paris à longjumeau bien après
puissions reprendre l'avion allait en
nouvelle calédonie patrick nous si vous
êtes d'accord avec ce deuxième sujet et
ce référendum qui entérine donc
l'appartenance de la région à la france
puisque 56 7 % des électeurs ont voté
non à une accession à l'indépendance
avec une participation élevée de 80% un
résultat qui a mis en joie notre
président de la république et notre
premier ministre comme vous allez
pouvoir l'écouter je veux 6 10
la fierté pour le chef de l'état que la
majorité des calédoniens et choisit la
france c'est pour nous une marque de
confiance dans la république française
dans son avenir est dans ses valeurs le
scrutin qui s'est déroulé hier est un
véritable succès démocratique et
populaire
je note d'ailleurs avec beaucoup de
satisfaction que tous s'accordent sur le
caractère incontestable du résultat de
ce référendum pouvait noter que leur
joie était quand même assez relative
mais quand même
ilana sécurel vous réjouissez sans
réserve de ce résultat mais pendant la
pause mais il était dit à ses succès
d'euros car bien sûr c'est un peu lourd
il faut se rendre à césar ce qui est à
césar
je pense que la grande faute c'est qu'on
a été capable on a été capable
collectivement et collectivement il
s'agit pas de faire du triomphalisme
idiot et personne ne le fait c'est qu'on
a été capable de mener un processus long
sur 30 ans qui est arrivé à à la phase
qui est la clé celle devant laquelle
nous sommes qui s'est bien passé quand
même sur le plan démocratique avec 80%
de participation un résultat qui est
reconnu et toute façon c'est une
situation complexe donc ya pas de raison
qu une situation complexe tout d'un coup
deviennent invalides par un incendie en
tant que résultat quand marie crac'h 56
cependant son s'est passé c'est quand
même les sondages donnait 70 % pour le
non et qu'au final on est plus à 30
centimes c'est une victoire en trompe
l'oeil quand même donc forcément c'est
pas la victoire parce qu'il ya un
problème dans ces accords de nouméa
quand et signe il ya 30 il ya vingt ans
exactement
c'est qu'ils permettent de faire jusqu'à
trois référendum je pas pourquoi il est
mis ça dans les accords à l'époque parce
que c'est quand même par les deux jours
quoi comme tous les deux ans donc en un
qui est prévue théoriquement en 2020 et
un autre en 2022
6e un score de 70 % pour le non les
laisse les autres discussions voilà
l'étonnant d'une aurait pu dire
maintenant voilà il ya un score massif
maintenant on passe à autre chose
là maintenant les indépendantistes ils
ont tout l'argument de dire on va aller
au parlement régional dont va redemander
un nouveau référendum et se réfère à
doubler en deux ans dans quatre ans on
sait pas ce qui peut donner et l'avenir
de la nouvelle calédonie il est encore
en pointillés et c'est pour ça que le
mot clé c'est dialogue n'est pas dicté
war dont l'une va longtemps par didier
est ce que ta victoire pour qui une
victoire pour la france qui a son
intérêt de rester dans cette région
d'asie pacifique surtout sur une île qui
je crois à elle seule entre 15 et 25%
des réserves de nickel mondiale
maintenant est ce que c'est une
est-ce que c'est un référendum pacifiant
pas forcément parce que je crois que
c'est environ 85 à 90% des kanaks qui
ont voté pour l'indépendance et cette
indépendance elle était demandée par les
kanaks alors qu'est ce qu'on fait en
fait ici ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui c'est
que la totalité de la population de
nouvelle-calédonie ne veut pas
l'indépendance
est ce qu'on sait aussi c'est que la
très grande majorité de la population
kanak veut l'indépendance et qu'elle
voudra dance 2 ans et qu'elle voudra
dans quatre ans et donc les problèmes
qui sont survenus dans les années 80
potentiellement peuvent ressurgir demain
c'est d'autant plus inquiétant que à
l'époque dans les années 80 quand il ya
eu des échauffourées à des événements en
dise il y avait une vraie problèmes
économiques
effectivement les kanaks avaient très
peu d'argent est que depuis 30 ans une
vraie politique a été menée pour leur
rendre de l'argent pour faire des
transferts sociaux on leur a donné deux
cent mille hectares de terres ce qui est
quand même énorme
entre temps là le parti indépendantiste
kanak
ks a construit une usine de traitement
du nickel ce qui a permis de financer
c'est dans ce qu'il s'est passé des
choses
cinquante pour cent de la population
kanak via noumea donc vite dans une
endroit il ya énormément caldoches mais
pour autant pour autant malgré tout ça
85 % d'entre eux veulent l'indépendance
alors le problème c'est que on parle de
décolonisation c'est vrai que c'est une
colonisation qui ne s'est pas des
colonisés que on demande cette fois ci à
l'intégralité de la population ça l'est
pour l'indépendance alors qu'en fait si
on décolonisons devrait juste demandé au
kanak comme on l'a fait pour les
catalans je suis désolé et que
évidemment l'intégralité de la
population d'irak toujours dans cette
indépendance mais les caennais voudront
toujours l'indépendance donc je ne vois
pas en quoi c'est classifiant ya comme
une chose qui a changé depuis les années
80 4,88 d'ailleurs vincent routes ou
dans les missions des décrypteurs too
loud figaro évoqué ça c'est le sait la
tonalité du discours des
indépendantistes je vous proposais et je
vous donne la parole après patrick
pelloux d'écouté europe a mis tant que
leader indépendantiste kanak y parlait
ce matin à
mais à écouter la tonalité de ses propos
ça quand même rien à voir avec ce qu'on
entendait en termes de violence verbale
ya 30 ans nous sommes persuadés au vu de
ces résultats que le projet politique
porté par le fn ps devient quelque chose
de possible
c'est une alternative puisque de
nombreux l'an canal en beauté lui à ce
référendum savons très bien les ce qui
nous lie à cette france savons très bien
ce que nous réduit à cette europe mais
pas dans la manière dont ça se fait à
l'heure actuelle parce que l'état ne
peut pas continuer à être une autorité
de tutelle et nous un territoire non
autonome mineurs n'ont donc les propos
sont plus modérées mais l'idée quand
même là même c'est à terme de se séparer
de la france non ce que je crois pas
parce que on est sorti progressivement
grâce aux accords de regard d'une
situation insurrectionnelle enfin il ya
les gendarmes ont été tués
dehiba où a été assassiné c'est pas rien
si c'est vraiment une vraie guerre
on s'en est sorti maintenant la
dépendance la décolonisation je pense
pas que ça soit là la question car on
sait très bien que des îles aussi
éloignées tombe raide de toute façon
sous le diktat d'autres puissances
mondiales mais qui ne sont plus
l'australie comme à l'époque mais plutôt
le chinois l'a plutôt la chine où rouler
ou les états unis
donc je je je crois moi je préfère que
ça reste et qu'on en fasse justement une
sorte de singularité démocratique mais
là c'est justement la démocratie qui
parlent en effet me suis bien d'accord
avec ça si le non l'avait remporté tout
le monde aurait dit on va essayer c'est
terminé reprenez vos gendarmes
votre structure de l'état pour devenir
quoi quelque part il ya une espèce en
effet on ya des richesses qui sont
exploitées par la france la france
développe et ed
ce pays le moi je trouve que c'est un
résultat qu'il faut respecter et qui est
tout à fait respectable puisque c'est
leur choix et il a encore c'est la
démocratie c'est pas le pouvoir des
armes qui a parlé sur les internautes
les résultats du référendum en nouvelles
colonies sont ils une victoire en trompe
l'oeil selon vous 47% oui 53% non c'est
assez équilibré
jean-baptiste marteau vous qui avez
suivi de près le web d'un sujet et pas
seulement ce week-end pour france 2 vous
avez le sentiment qu'il ya quand même un
projet crédit de la part des
indépendantistes or puissance étrangère
ou quand même il ya la france il faut
rappeler la métropole 1 voit plus d'un
milliard et demi d'euros par an
notamment pour la fonction publique aura
effectivement le pib quand même la
nouvelle calédonie qui s'est beaucoup
améliorée depuis dix ans on peut penser
qu'il y avait non pas un avenir pour
l'indépendance mais en tout cas une
situation économique qui permette de le
préparer de manière un peu plus calme et
tranquille qu'il ya dix ans maintenant
ce résultat il ne règle pas toutes
façons de problèmes et il va se reposer
de deux ans dans quatre ans parce qu'il
ya une volonté indépendantiste qui reste
très fort de tous les kanaks et pas que
parce qu'effectivement c'est ce que dit
le leader indépendantiste le oui quand
on regarde dans le détail il est
majoritaire dans des zones qui n'étaient
jusque là pas habité par les kanaks ou
plutôt par des européens
donc on va se retrouver à son la
situation va se reposer c'est vrai qu'on
a réussi à organiser ce référendum
c'était déjà une victoire on voit la
situation il ya 20 ans oui à part trois
voitures ont brûlé donc c'est vraiment
sans incident maintenant la situation va
de toute façon se reposer dans la même
situation dans deux ans dans 95 niveau
d'antan d'autant qu'en plus ce que
veulent les indépendantistes n'est pas
une indépendance pure et dure et ensuite
on se tape dans la main qui s'est
terminée il envisage plutôt une
collaboration avec l'état français est
récupérée en fait tous leurs pouvoirs
régaliens mais éventuellement déléguer
une partie
réjean paul coll
ce que déjà les autonomies un
représentant aux ambassades de nouvelle
zélande et australie ils ont une salle
oms ils ont un représentant à l'onu
c'est d'ailleurs un laboratoire de la
décolonisation si on peut dire ou de
l'autonomie c'est un cas unique
aucun autre département d'état ça n'a ce
statut est sûre la chine il ya quelque
chose d'intéressant à savoir c'est que
compte tenu de leurs réserves de nickel
les indépendantistes se sentent vraiment
fort pour négocier vis-à-vis de la chine
et ils ont d'ailleurs construire une
usine de nickel en chine la nouvelle les
néo calédoniens en fait contrôler les
cinq usines de nickel trois en nouvelle
calédonie et deux autres dans le reste
de l'asie ils ont construit une usine en
chine les indépendantistes de gauche et
la loi chinoise interdit dès qu'une
société chinoise étrangères donne la
majorité de son capital à des étrangers
ils ont dit ah mais si nous avons pas la
majorité vous n'aurez pas d' usine
voilà donc ils ont réussi ces petits
calédonien à faire changer la loi
chinoise
donc ils se sont assez confortable pour
pour être indépendant et pour être nos
taux même si personne aujourd'hui ne
peut dire s'ils sont suffisamment riches
pour se passer des 14 % de pib que leur
donne l'état français sous forme de
transferts financiers
c'est un argument pour qu'il reste en
france et il leur dira qu'ils ont toute
leur place dans le pays ces derniers
mois donnent à ce qu elle si jamais dans
deux ans ou dans quatre ans le nguyen
indépendance passe est ce qu'il ya un
risque de l'exemple de modèles qui
donnerait des idées à d'autres
territoires ou départements d'outre-mer
je pense que c'est relativement
spécifique mais pour terminer pour
conclure je pense que le prénom de la
république a su garder la bonne distance
et assume manif et c'est pas mal de
l'europe est certain le reprocher un peu
trop et je pense que c'est important de
faire en sorte que les voix soient
entendues et de ne pas je pense qu'un
excès d'interventionnisme mauvais bord
était tout à fait mal placé je pense que
ça c'est pour ses unes des unes des
raisons je pense du bon déroulement des
scrutins retour en france métropolitaine
avec ce projet qui semble prendre son
mal elysées si on en croit notre
confrère l'opinion ce matin qui titre
loi de 1905 les choix de macron la loi
de 1905 vous savez c'est cette fameuse
loi de séparation des églises et de
l'état
je vois pas très écolo qui reposent déjà
les manches que certains considèrent
comme insuffisantes pour faire face à
l'intégrisme islamiste d'où la volonté
de réforme et notamment le régime des
cultes tels qu'il est édictée dans les
articles 18 à 36 par exemple avec l'idée
de créer une sorte de label de l'état
pour autoriser la création des
associations cultuelles
je sens que vous ne trouvez pas que
c'est une bonne idée patrick que l'oua
faut absolument pas toucher à la loi
1905 c'est un tabou un totem c'est un
totem un totem
même si la soirée pour la trahison ça
s'est passé beaucoup de choses depuis le
moment là vous dites aussi que
l'existence même de la france
il faut faire évoluer un peu la france
depuis n'ont cessé sa structure et les
choses sa structure et les choses pour
plein d'arguments
la loi 1905 ses racines c'est la commune
de paris ça c'est une évidence ou c'est
là où on remet en cause la présence des
cultes et ça mûrit dans la société ça
mûrit au parlement et il saneh et ça
fait quelque chose qui est important
parce que c'est discerner alors c'est
sûr qu'on ait un on est un satellite par
rapport aux autres pays dont on va faire
des commémorations du 11-novembre
j'imagine même les états unis la
présence des religions est importante
tas d'endroits où yves lallemand voilà
les république islamique
il y en a pleins partout mais nous on
est singulier et 7 la séparation des
religions par rapport à la société c'est
une indépendance intellectuelle et
morale il faut pas les faire rentrer
dans le jeu politique
c'est vraiment c'est un truc qui est
sacré ils veulent ils veulent ils
veulent
les politiques en amont sentiment c'est
pour les encadrer mais encadré rien du
tout vous leur donnez ça ils vont vous
bouffez ça et alors autant je pense que
les catholiques défendront la laïcité
les autres non les autres noms vous
verrez mais c'est une erreur
la cité où il dira que ça vient de
vendre c'est justement nicole belloubet
garde des sceaux ce matin sur france
inter pour écouter ses arguments ce qui
est important c'est réellement que nous
puissions ensemble travailler sur un
islam de france qui apporte de
l'apaisement par rapport aux questions
liées à cette religion
ça veut dire quoi concrètement sur le
mode de financement par exemple sur sur
la formation des imams et cetera ya
plusieurs chants qui peuvent être
travaillés en masse ont besoin humain la
maaf écureuils oui alors écoutez j'ai
l'impression si vous voulez j'aimerais
bien qu'on sorte vous avec martin buber
puisqu'on aime bien les auteurs à votre
émission grand philosophe disait qu'un
vrai dialogue c'est quand on sort tous
un petit peu transformé par rapport à
quand on était arrivé alors transformer
l'ensemble mais bon nous les uns les
autres
non j'ai l'impression que grosso modo on
est absolument d'accord moi je suis une
fervente adepte de la laïcité à la
française mais je crois que notre
président aussi c'est la bonne nouvelle
que j'amène il n'est pas question de
revenir sur les principes qui fondent la
loi de 1905 à savoir la séparation des
églises et de l'état personne n'y songe
d'ailleurs nicole belloubet le rappelait
ce matin
mais pour moi c'est une évidence et pour
le prénom de la république aussi donc de
quoi s'agit-il
d'abord on parle d'une fuite donc on
reviendra peut-être en parler quand ce
sera absolument sûr puisqu'on parle d'un
d'éventuel il ya eu 2 mai 13 ou 14
amendements depuis le début du mois et
en tout cas c'est pas officiels comme
vous savez donc c'est eu pour l'instant
on en est donc je serai plus à l'aise de
vous parler quand ce sera officiel parce
que c'est un travail en cours
donc on pourrait parler plus
sérieusement exactement
les amendements des ajustements qui sont
envisagées je répète qu'il est hors de
question et au plus haut niveau de
l'état de remettre en cause ce qui fait
le fondement de notre société française
à savoir la séparation de l'église et de
l'état est le fait des églises et de
l'état et du fait qu' il n'y aura jamais
de financement public de d'un quelconque
culte
donc ça ce n'est pas ça qui est en jeu
maintenant on a tous constaté depuis à
certains un certain temps pardon de
prendre un tout petit peu de recul qu'il
ya un certain nombre de problèmes qui se
sont posés et qui n'était pas posée par
la loi d'abord parce que l'islam
n'existait pas et ensuite parmi ces
problèmes y en un qui sur le cabinet
système une femme il était il est et il
était extrêmement minorités en france et
donc il ne nie le problème n'a pas été
pensé à sa bonne mesure mais il ya un
autre phénomène qui s'est développée et
là dessus nous rejoindrons probablement
c'est l'apparition et le développement
d'un islam politique et cette loi et ce
dispositif beaucoup de gens le combat
politique par nature ils n'ont l'essai
mais pas pour une armature sa politique
est en train de se développer dans notre
pays qui est identifié qui est identifié
comme un danger et il se trouve que les
amendements envisagés vont plutôt dans
le sens de la transparence la
transparence financière effectivement
pour effective et d'autre part sur un
plus grand contrôle
donc en réalité j'ai l'impression un peu
d'un dialogue de sourd si vous permettez
s'engagent eux parce que il ne s'agit
pas tout d'un coup d'ouvrir toutes les
vannes et jeu en se disant voilà on
remet en cause un tout petit peu de la
loi et donc forcément c'est pour en
abattre les fondements
non les fondements ne seront pas remis
en cause oui il y à des amendements qui
sont peut-être prévu on attendra qu'ils
soient officiels pour pouvoir vraiment
en débattre de manière plus technique
mais en tout cas le problème de la
montée l'islam politique il est posé le
problème des financements de l'islam par
des pays étrangers et du coup qui
alimente un radicalisme il est posé il
faut trouver des réponses et et le
problème d'un islam de france dans
lequel
ne voulaient pas croire mais qu'il faut
tenter de construire parce que vous avez
des musulmans de france il ya un islam
en france
l'idée est ce assez je pense que ce qui
ce qui fait la marque aujourd'hui du
grain de la république par rapport à ces
questions c'est que il identifie des
problèmes comme ses prédécesseurs mais
au lieu du relais en disant il ya des
problèmes il ya un problème avec l'islam
après la mecque islam comme avec
beaucoup de sujets il a décidé d'y
travailler sérieusement et de prendre
son temps vous l'avez noté de prendre
son temps pour essayer d'aboutir à des
solutions dont on pourra débattre mais
je voudrais comme en soient d'accord sur
l'heure les intentions wade veut dire
qu'on ne diabolise pas l'intention en se
disant que l'objectif c'est d'arriver à
des financements plus transparent à
éviter que l'islam en france soit
instrumentalisée par des des forces
radicales qui sont parfois dépassés par
des financements jean-baptiste marteau
bien que non vous parlez d intention d'
emmanuel macron c'est vrai qu'a priori
on peut ne pas en douter le problème
c'est que il y là encore je vous dirais
quelques preuves à faire sur la laïcité
le discours des bernardins a pour
beaucoup de français très attachés à la
laïcité se met un petit peu le trouble
et donc se demande effectivement ce
qu'il a vraiment derrière la tête sur la
laïcité c'est un totem la loi de 1905
effectivement et dès qu'on commence à
toucher peut-être même un petit
centimètre
mais il faudrait pas arrivés à l'hôtel
je tabou qui fait qu'on n'arrive plus à
trouver de solutions sur le principe on
peut se dire quand il dit il sauve à
mieux encadrer le financement étranger
venu pour le financer des mosquées par
exemple en le limitant à 10000 euros ce
qui est à peu près d'un an les fuites
qui sont sortis ce matin et au delà se
seraient contrôlés bon sur le principe
pourquoi pas on peut tous est d'accord
sur cette mesure mais quand au derrière
va pas tous ou presque mais non mais on
peut dire qu'en tout cas pourquoi pas le
le le
l'état d'esprit l'état des lieux c'est
le faire une erreur
eux se défendent en tout cas je ferai
juste après avec plaisir bernardin si
derrière on commence effectivement à
permettre aux associations cultuelles de
posséder leur bien d'avoir des revenus
qui en découlent
c'est ce qu'il ya dans le scond a lu ce
matin avec pourquoi pas des financements
publics pour arriver pour refaire
l'isolation le ce genre de choses c'est
tout ce qu'on a pu lire et on se dit que
effectivement le principe de la loi de
1905 peut être détournée à travers des
financements qui vont venir ici ou là
par les collectivités locales aussi on
le voit plusieurs fois la fin lors de la
construction de mosquées
il ya quand même un site qu'ils ont
baissé leur culotte par rapport à l'or
principe car lié à l'entente juste avant
chez nos internautes emmanuel macron
ont-ils raison de vouloir réformer la
loi de 1905 sur la séparation des dîners
d'état non à 68% dans deux tiers de nos
internautes se sont essayés au style 120
jours de sa présidence la réforme et non
formés série oui mais là je crois que
l'argument c'est un pays où il peut lui
aussi un peu croient vous est temps pour
réfléchir alors que grosso modo il nous
ressort la même chose le club est dans
le tout le rapport et karoui de
septembre 2016 et tout le monde sait
parfaitement tous les gens qui suivent
la vie politique je pense que vous en
êtes savent parfaitement que depuis
toujours
il avait en tête de mettre en place cet
islam de france est une des raisons pour
lesquelles du camp des bernardins été si
critiquées
c'est pas sur le fond parce que c'était
assez un mode où c'était moins en fait
sur le fond françois lévesque en
terminant 7e devant la conférence des
évêques de france directement mais
c'était moi sur le fait
salut à tous sur le fond tu que c'était
cause s'étaient vu comme une façon de
préparer l'opinion à la mise en place
d'un islam de france
alors il vaut réfléchir emmanuel macron
et vous savez quoi ce qui serai sympa
c'est quand même qu'il écoute les gens
qui connaissent leur sujet parce que
manifestement je ne sais pas qu'il a
autour de lui et j'ai l'impression que
il est entouré de nuls insupportable non
mais moi on est dans un malentendu sur
un point et là il nous faudrait beaucoup
plus de temps mais il n'est or il n'est
pas absolument pas question là encore il
faut s'entendre sur les mots d'avoir un
l'état qui tout d'un coup devient
puissance de décision de l'islam de
france il s'agit de l'islam de france
est bien plein
c'est ça le monde le modèle c'est ce
n'est c'est ce qui peut se passer pour
pour les juifs de france à travers par
exemple une taxe halal qui pourrait
permettre avec son v10 1890
aujourd'hui vous avez cinq millions de
musulmans premièrement deuxièmement vous
dit que l'islam n'est pas politique mais
une fois de plus je trouve surprenant
que en 2018 en novembre 2018 et encore
des hauts responsables qui explique que
l'islam est pas politique qu'en volume
sans salle vous explique que destinée
politique connaît le sujet il habite en
algérie et il est en train de dire il a
parlé lui du rapport car oui pour une
fois et pas que du sondage il a parlé du
rapport lui-même pour dire que le
rapport el karoui c'était d'islamisation
de la france comme il avait connu en
algérie siwarak il noir à qui il a écrit
un livre pourquoi je ne suis pas
musulman
il connaît parfaitement l'islam et vous
dira que les samedis politique dina bell
rhazoui elle a donné des cours en egypte
elle connaît parfaitement l'islam elle
n' maroc ne vous dira que c'est ça mais
politique et vous nous expliquer il
s'aimait politique c'est la politique
depuis le départ nous avons en france
effectivement un nombre important de
musulmans
un grand nombre d'entre eux ne sont pas
dans la radicalité le phénomène du raki
levin mise et attendait le film domaine
de la radicalité est préoccupant très
préoccupant il est pris en charge par
jean michel blanquer par un comité des
sages présidé par dominique schnapper
donc les choses sont identifiés je ne
peux pas vous laisser dire c'est d'avoir
tous les musulmans sont engagés dans un
processus en général un politique c'est
une c'est 1-1 sympa demain qui veut et
qui veut identifier un islam radical
si ce n'est pas républicain pas du tout
la politique on va être prêt si oui
c'est quoi l'islam politique ni somme et
politiques de manière générale il se
trouve que en france pendant très
longtemps on a eu un modèle
d'intégration qui a transformé des
musulmans en musulman républicain par
ailleurs et se désole ne s'habille en
écrasant rennes intégration voyez vous
que emmanuel macron est en train
d'abandonner petit à petit voilà c'est
ça le problème
mais faux mais c'est quoi une célèbre
l'etic plaide abandonnant et pas
finalement
l'audace d'essayer de tenter de gaza
voir avec une audace parce qu'il ya une
logique derrière tout ça il ya une
logique cette logique en effet mais le
prédécesseur nicolas sarkozy avait
essayé déjà de faire l'islam de france
ils auront ouvert des portes ils ont ils
ont dit voilà on va faire le culte
musulman du conseil conseil du grand
sahara t c'est un échec c'est après
quand vous regardez oui enfants vous
regardez ses instances quand il ya eu
des attentats
il y en a il a fallu vraiment leur
arracher le fait qu'il dénonçait des
attentats et c'est ça c'est ça le
problème c'est d'accous ils comprennent
la violence ça ne peut pas que je vais
dire un truc nous qu'est ce qu'on fait
là qu'est-ce qui ces manuels macron il
arrive avec il a fuité est organisée ne
prenons pas les gens trop pour des
nouilles quand même je trouve cela pas
là deux études il ya eu des centaines
d'amendements qui disent il dit pas
tellement ce que vous avez écrit il dit
voilà je vais proposer un nouveau statut
aux associations et je vais rendre ce
statut attractif en leur permettant de
posséder des immeubles et de les
exploiter
et puis par ailleurs en leur permettant
également de bénéficier de subventions
d'état pour la rénovation énergétique de
ces immeubles hautement qu'est ce qu'ils
en fait qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
l'autrichien qu'est ce qu'il a fait à la
place il a dit vous savez quoi
moi je vous dis tout de suite les
financements étrangers c'est interdit et
c'est pas interdit au dessus de 10000
euros
c'est interdit point barre voilà et les
financements en allemagne le manga n'est
pas très loin reconnecter le nom mais
sauf si vous faites plein de 3
mégapixels est plafonné à 2000 euros et
il savait ce qui se passait ce que vous
pensez c'est une finition étrangers
l'islam de france tout en rappelant
comment on finance les mosquées mis ses
pommes ce financement sinon il a fait le
saut l'historien tout seul quand il agit
mais tout à fait de cela l'état pense
qu'il est mort mais il s'agit de
d'apporter une réflexion et une aide
pour que justement cette organisation
est ce qu'elle ne se fasse pas au
détriment des musulmans les plus
modulaires du pays premièrement l'islam
politique
on ne finance pas une chose bien que
l'argent nerf de la guerre c'est pas les
acquis 20 c'est noir et ses faux pas de
la guerre elle-même et le problème c'est
que premièrement il ya énormément d'un
journal islam et même beaucoup d'argent
aux puces
vous savez peut-être ou sur nous tous
j'espère pour vous en tout cas que en
islamisme ne vous parle pas d'islam ne
prennent pas les musulmans mais les
islamistes refuse de payer de l'état de
l'argent des impôts à l'étape où fars
la lutte avec raison les énormément
d'argent qui est ce qui passe en dessous
qui passent pas sous le radar de la
fiscalité
quand on a écrit une france soumise aux
lois du refus il faut que j'ai eu au
téléphone une une contrôleuse fiscale on
n'a pas pu témoigner son publié son
témoignage parce que dernier moment elle
a reculé mais qui nous expliquait que
les sociétés de certification halal dans
son dans sa région où elles vivent et où
il y avait énormément d'un rabot
musulmans et dans sa commune il avait
énormément de commercial avait 0%
chiffre d'affaires non 0 % de chiffre
d'affaires soit que maintenant les lois
jeudi c'est elle moi je ne peux pas
déclencher une inspection investigations
fiscales sont prouvés à ma supérieure
hiérarchique et je vais avoir 50 mille
euros de bénéfices
or comme j'ai zéro compte et qui sont 0
sur leurs comptes bancaires et 0 sur
leurs pointes sociaux je ne peux pas
prouver que j'avais à 50000 euros mais
il ya ensuite je m'étais renseigné
auprès des gens qui connaissent bien la
sécurité il ya des millions des millions
d'euros qui circulent en sous cape et
qui resteront en tout cas pas ce que je
vais dire les islamistes jamais iront
adopter votre truc là d'associations
pour avoir trois balles issus de
l'exploitation leur immeuble alors
qu'ils ont des centaines de milliers
d'euros ce que votre arrivée c'est
précisément ce contre quoi nous voulons
lutter en proposant une organisation
plus de transparence et plus de
structuration écoutez boualem sansal
échos viser bien le faire mais non vous
le lisez un grand respect sinon il vous
a expliqué vous auriez entendu quand il
a dit au prix varenne de la fondation
prix de la fondation gérée par haine des
journalistes en 2016 il a dit l'islam de
france n'existera pas l'islam est
partout chez lui
vous pensez que quel musulman se
soumettra aux desiderata d'un état mais
cris mais franchement merci contre ce
débat on va juste terminée mission sur
le note un petit peu plus c'est vraiment
le début c'est le débat c'est le débat
inférieur aux autres et qu'on accepte
par ailleurs hier vous noterez copé
parce que de responsables ici c'est la
loi de la république oui et c'est le
fait de leur dire qu'ils n'ont pas le
droit d'agir comme ils le font
profession musulmans humaniste
et pas de gastines belval n'a pas de
l'islamisme savez quoi je crois que nous
allons je crois que nous allons refaire
un débat très vite chaud sur ce sujet
juste pour terminer un mot sur cette
oeuvre
juste pour terminer on n'a plus que deux
minutes un mot sur cette annonce de
fabrice luchini de sa candidature
éventuelle avec annie française est ce
que vous trouvez çà bizare décalé
lui-même a dit j'ai d'abord à redire que
je n'étais qu'un saltimbanques doublé
d'un doublé d'un mauvais caractère mais
je crois que je me lançais et tenter de
me faire élire à la cani français il a
dit ça dans le figaro magazine vous
trouvé ça magnifique et qu'elle est
géniale
dès qu'elle est géniale la patrie ou là
là je sens dans l'orient non mais je
pense qu'il aurait dû demander à
conduire la navette spatiale
le président des états unis ça suffise
ici aussi le qui promet de ne pas
toucher à la loi de séparation des
églises et de l'état vous êtes d'accord
à dire qu'il vous occuper des ducs est
touché par sa fédération et je suis non
seulement touché mais ce qui met
immédiatement venu à l'esprit
justement en tant que personnes
particulièrement en charge de
l'éducation c'est la magnifique lettre
d'albert camus à son instituteur germain
quand il a reçu le prix nobel en dix ans
la première personne juste après ma mère
à laquelle j'ai pensé c'est vous et bien
comme les instituteurs faudra peut-être
pensé à faire entrer les grands
instituteur luchini est un
extraordinaire passeur et alors c'est un
passeur formidable de c'est un exemple
aussi c'est un exemple pour notre
jeunesse avec un parcours personnel qui
2 de sons de partir de l'album tu as est
arrivé à à la culture et il offre la
culture comme personne donc si
effectivement 6 en 1 qu'il mérite
c'est bien lui donc il ya même pas débat
entre nous je déconne et jean petit nom
merkel et parce qu'effectivement c'est
ce qu'on se disait tout à l'heure le but
de l'académie c'est quand même d'écrire
un dictionnaire c'est pas un grand
écrivain sans papiers mais c'est un tel
acteur appel oui passeur de cultures ce
quand on parle culture avec lui au bout
de cinq minutes on est subjugué
tous les deux sont la langue française
ils défont un feu et de celle sur l'oral
qu'à l'écrit
c'est gentil
c'est bien aussi l'interprète et quand
on interprète ont écrit pas convaincu
patrick pelloux toujours là mais c'est
très bien pour le fait du conflit c'est
parce qu'on va continuer coran terminera
cette conversation merci en tout cas
tous les quatre d'être venus figurent
live c'est fini pour aujourd'hui point
de vue pardon c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui mais revient dès demain avec
marie amélie lombarde la tuna demain
bonsoir
[Musique]